كثيرا عن محيط ملعب الثمامه او الجار
البيضاء او الرباط او اي مدينه عربيه
الجميع هنا توحد خلف منتخب عربي يحمل
الطموحات العربيه في مونديال العرب في
دوحه العرب الكل
قبل دقائق من نهايه المباراه بدات
الاحتفالات بالفعل ببلوغي المربع الذهبي
في انجاز تاريخي والكثيرون هنا
لم يرثين لكنهم اليوم
طول ماما شعور كبير ولا يصف وصور المنتخب
الوطني المغربي نصف نهايه كاس العالم فهذا
تمثيل الكره العرب وكل دول افريقيا همم
شاشه من كل العرب كل افريقيا بالتحديد خلف
المنتخب الوطني فا شكرا القطري لتحفينا
الفرصه انه نحضروا هذه العرس وتشجعوا
المنتخب
ان شاء الله وتاهلون النهائيات كاس العالم
يا سلام
الى بعض الاطفال الفئات الصينيه هنا
مختلفه كيف تشعر بعد فوز المغرب
سعيد
[موسيقى]
اخرى ايضا تحتفل
المنتخب المغربي
ورئيس كريستيانو رونالدو
الله كيف تشعرين بعد الوصول الى مربع
الذهبي
ما هي رسالتك للاعبين
من هذا المنبر
كمخيمين بقطر واللي جاء حتى همزيه شرفتونا
يا اسود شرفتونا يا رجال ديما مغرب شكرا
بزاف بزاف فرحتيني
ان شاء الله النهائي وكان يحييكم